Speaker 1: Donald Trump also now hitting
back at Ron DeSantis and going with an
attempted homophobic smear suggesting that Ron
DeSantis may be gay. Yes, it is March of 2023,
and this is where we are. Donald Trump apparently
out of ideas going with. It's possible that
DeSantis might be into men rather than into women.
I don't I know. It's crazy. I know it's crazy.
Donald Trump posting to Truth Social. In response
to De Santos's recent statements about the Trump
looming indictment, which we just looked at,
quote, Ron does sanctimonious will probably
find out about false accusations and fake stories
sometime in the future as he gets older, wiser,
and better known when he's unfairly and illegally
attacked by a woman, even classmates that are
underage or possibly a man. I'm sure he will want
to fight these misfits just like I do. And again,
this is only a smear to homophobic people, right?
If I found out a candidate I liked or was thinking
about supporting were gay, I would say, Oh, I
don't care about that. What are their policies?
But to a group of people that would immediately
not consider voting for a candidate that was
gay or might be gay, suggesting that there may be
men who come out of the woodwork is a smear. Now,
when you look at the exact language of it, it sort
of seems like Trump would be saying, well, these
would be false allegations against the Santos.
But still, it's that idea that with DeSantis, it
might be men who come out of the woodwork and then
following up on this attack with another attack,
attack on truth, social truth.
Speaker 2: Essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. Ron does sanctimonious is
dropping in the polls so fast that he soon may be
falling behind young Vivek Ramaswamy. People are
beginning to find out that Ron wanted to destroy
Social Security and raise its minimum age to at
least 70. He also had strong plans for cutting
Medicare and still does. Nothing good happens when
you are a disciple of super RINO Paul Ryan. Also,
Florida did great long before Desanctis came
along. Got my coveted Capital E endorsement,
shot up like a rocket and won. And of course,
I won't look at the polls a second time with
you because we just looked at them in a recent
segment. But it is not true that DeSantis is
falling in the polls. DeSantis is doing roughly
just as well as he has been doing. He does better
against Trump in head to head. Matchups. DeSantis
doing worse against Trump. When you include Nikki
Haley and a whole bunch of other people that might
run for that Republican nomination. So this is a
full blown civil war right now. Trump with a
looming arrest, going after DeSantis, DeSantis
going after Trump. And later, what you will see is
Don Jr's involvement in this. But that is going to
be much later today. We're going to take a short
break. And next, I want to look at this is really
something else. Our friends from the Good Liars,
Jason and Avram, they went to the lower Manhattan,
quote, protest yesterday against Trump's arrest.
They were interviewed by Right Side Broadcasting
Network. And it is the stuff of legend. So
we're going to look at that after a quick break.